was ist denn bitte mit 2.020 los
plötzlich gute nachrichten
trump abgewählt und ein corona impfstoff
in greifbarer nähe
wahnsinn oder obendrein noch einer aus
deutschland wäre 2020 eine fernsehserie
würde ich sagen das staffelfinale ist
ein bisschen sehr schmutzig geraten zur
total unglaubwürdig so und noch eine
gute nachricht man hat es tatsächlich
geschafft schneiden sie sich an am 11.11
karneval zu verhindern
in köln war aber knapp es sind so rund
100 personen von corona leugnern
und sie versuchen natürlich grenzen
auszutesten man hat mal versucht kurz zu
schunkeln aber dann sind die kollegen
sofort eingeschritten
gott sei dank junge junge beim ersten
schunkel versuch ist direkt die
berittene polizei rhein galoppiert finde
ich übrigens super auch nach krone
aber zurück zum impfstoff mit entwickelt
von der deutschen firma biontech 300
millionen dosen hat sich die eu diese
woche schon gesichert allein 100 für uns
germany first wird trotzdem wohl lange
dauern bis wir alle unsere spritze
hatten da sind diskussionen
vorprogrammiert
ich möchte das idealerweise an jedem
mittagstisch auf arbeit wo auch immer
menschen miteinander reden in
deutschland darüber geredet wird was
denkst du
wer sollte eigentlich zuerst geimpft
werden wenn der impfstoff knapp ist ich
hätte sonst man ja entschuldigung der
impfstoff kommt aus mainz da macht es ja
schon logistisch und wegen der kurzen
wege total sinn wenn zuerst zdf
mitarbeiter geimpft werden ja natürlich
klar
der firmensitz von biontech übrigens in
mainz an der goldgrube 12 weil die
sachen kannst du dir gar nicht ausdenken
gut der langweilige deutsche ethikrat
findet als erstes sollen risikogruppen
geimpft werden die alten zum beispiel
naja dann pflegepersonal haben die nicht
im frühjahr schon den ganzen applaus von
den balkonen gekriegt ich frag ja nur
nur eine frage
laut hersteller soll das zeug bei über
90 prozent der menschen wirken
und nein es wird keine impfpflicht geben
kann man scheinbar nicht oft genug sagen
wir bleiben beim impfangebot ist wird zu
einer freiwilligen impfung kommen also
ja ich schließe aus dass es eine pflicht
gibt das ziel einer ausreichend hohen
impfquoten freiwillig erreichen gibt es
eine impfpflicht nein ich glaube dass
bill gates und zwangssterilisierten will
vielleicht nicht mit der ersten spritze
aber mit der sechsten natürlich
natürlich will das ist wie beim
überraschungs ei von jeder sechste
spritze wird mann unfruchtbar oder
gechipt keine ahnung deutschland das
land der dichter und querdenker gerade
wieder großdemo in leipzig mit der
üblichen mischung aus esoterisch
angehauchten impfgegner
plus eine prise wutbürger samt nazi
begleitung wohl bekomms wirklich es ist
ein rätsel warum das sächsische
oberverwaltungsgericht diese demo in der
leipziger innenstadt so genehmigt hat
warum wenn es war doch vollkommen klar
dass die querdenker weder abstände
einhalten noch masken tragen
so sind die halt was soll die polizei da
machen viele stellten die beamten aber
auch nicht für unternehmen dieser
politik zeigt den demonstranten sogar
deutlich seine unterstützung
super super beziehungsweise kurz zur
erinnerung deutschlands gastronomen und
die veranstaltungsbranche sind im
lockdown damit die zahlen vielleicht
doch mal runter gehen und die super
sprayer idioten da in leipzig treffen
sich zum rudel kuschelt kann doch nicht
wahr sein
man hätte die demo allein schon
verbieten müssen um diese bedrückenden
bilder zu verhindern
ich sage für den einsatz von bongo es
gibt es absolut keine rechtfertigung
auch nicht für lustige polonaisen
während gleichzeitig die intensivstation
ans limit kommen dann in den letzten
zwei wochen hat sich die zahl der kogit
intensivpatienten fast verdoppelt auf
über 3.000 vor allem fehlen ohne ende
pfleger dann nutzen intensivbetten auch
nix sind dann einfach nur möbel sondern
kannst du dir im prinzip auch bei ikea
kaufen tüte köttbullar gibt es gratis
dazu
klar ganz wichtig soll man über die
verhältnismäßigkeit der korona maßnahmen
streiten machen wir ja auch jede woche
aber die eigentliche gefahr bleibt doch
das virus oder andererseits vielleicht
liegt da wo die querdenker ihre
verschwörungen wittern für uns andere
auch eine chance
sie sagen es gibt viel zu wenig
impfdosen und bald doch zu wenig
intensivbetten alles lüge lüge lüge die
ganzen querdenker brauchen ja weder
impfstoff noch intensivbetten denn
corona gibt's ja gar nicht auch die
bekloppten die unser internet voll müll
mit sätzen wie ist doch nur eine grippe
alle direkt von der imf liste streichen
genau wie die jungs die einfach immer
weiter feiern plus familie wendler
wieder zwei impfdosen weniger geil idee
deutschland wird wieder geteilt
diesmal in eine geimpfte und eine
ungeimpfte zone und die ungeimpften
kriegen sagen wir mal baden württemberg
dann können wir wieder in den urlaub
fliegen oder fremden leuten die zunge in
den hals stecken und ihr impfgegner
macht was solche spaß macht
demonstrieren und so ach ja und falls
jedoch überraschend corona kriegt
versucht es doch wie immer mit
bachblüten toi toi toi und viel glück
eure bald geimpften
von mir auch toi toi toi ich behaupte
sogar im chat ist ein kategorischer
imperativ frei nach kant kleiner
akademiker manche querdenker gehen
übrigens noch einen ekelhaften schritt
weiter und pöbeln jetzt wahllos
passanten an weil die sich an die regeln
halten hier eine ihrer live
übertragungen ins internet mit
kameraschwenk auf eine familie die mund
nasen bedeckung trägt masken abrufen die
männer und machen vor allem der tochter
angst lassen sie es mich so formulieren
wie es sich für eine grimme preis
prämierte satiresendung geziemt was für
blöde [ __ ] was soll das denn
behaupten für grundrechte zu kämpfen und
schreien irgendwelche leute an
vielleicht der neue herbst trend
[Musik]
das wird ein langer harter winter
freunde aber dann
dann wird drauflos geimpft bis der arzt
kommt
wobei natürlich muss der biontech
impfstoff vorher noch weitere testphasen
durchlaufen ist ja klar
eine übrigens an der frankfurter börse
unter der leitung von dr birte schneider
produkte schneider was für experimente
sind das na ja der impfstoff wurde bis
jetzt an über 43.000 probanden getestet
dass es schön kann man machen aber wie
verträgt unser wichtigster patient das
zeug der dax das untersuchen wir hier
und es wird sie freuen zu erfahren
dem dax geht's super er hat den
impfstoff richtig gut vertragen am
montag mit der biontech nachricht direkt
500 punkte nach oben geschossen der
kleine racker ich kann meine
erleichterung kaum in worte fassen
musste man sich den sorgen machen um den
dax hallo im ersten lockdown im märz
tagen da hätte ich fast verloren
zum glück hat er dann sehr gut
angesprochen auf die massiven geld
infusion von olaf scholz nicht kollege
nicht nachlassen
ja das gefällt dir da freute sich du
bist ein ganz ein feiner du bist ein
feiner aber frau schneider hat der
rechnungshof nicht gerade letzte woche
kritisiert deutschland würde im schatten
von corona doch mehr schulden machen als
nötig
und über sind sie ihre der dax kann uns
hören man jetzt ist nicht die stunde der
erbsenzähler das ist doch toll dass der
staat so schnell und unbürokratisch
hilft nur so kann zum beispiel bmw seine
leute in kurzarbeit schicken und
gleichzeitig 1,6 milliarden dividenden
an aktionäre ausschütten verstehe und in
der kombination aus geldspritzen und
impfstoff wird jetzt aber alles gut zu
schnell aus dem krisenmodus ist auch
gefährlich
daleiden die ganzen pandemie profiteure
für bestimmte konzerne dürfte corona ja
noch ewig dauern ikea zum beispiel durch
die decke gegangen zalando die ganzen
lieferdienste und natürlich alles im dfb
tross ist an corona um sagenhafte 36
milliarden dollar reicher geworden
wer so glücklich wie kannst du quasi gar
nicht mehr interviewen und on top kommt
das fetteste amazon weihnachtsgeschäft
aller zeiten
apropos jeff bezos hat das perfekte
lockdown weihnachtsgeschenk für sie
entwickelt den masturbation roboter ein
traum wird wahr
laut ubs bank sind die milliardäre des
planeten allein von april bis juni um
ein viertel reicher geworden vorschlag
könnte man nicht wo olaf scholz
steuergeld bazooka vielleicht doch bald
keine munition mehr hat auf alles was
firmen durch corona zusätzlich verdienen
eine art corona sondersteuer draufhauen
vielen dank auch sie vollidiot man
schnell wenn mehr geld bleibt dran gehen
nicht ins licht durch die heute show
deutschlands zwei kabarettisten
sozialneid show nach die anstalt
[Musik]
was ich über meinen arsch geigensolo war
doch versprochen ihr könnt ihr in der
zeit den kanal abonnieren
[Musik]